taken three is directed by Olivier
Megaton and stars Liam Neeson fomka
Jenson and Forest Whitaker as well as
Maggie Grace and it's another taken
movie again now I really like the first
taken movie I mean I like it like I like
it a lot I actually watch it probably
once a year I think it's a very fun
action movie it was a great new thing to
see Liam Neeson killing people with this
pinkie finger and he just bought it he
was great in the movie taken to was
directed by Olivier Megaton just like
this one and it was terrible it featured
some of the worst film - action I've
ever seen so no I was not excited for
take 3 in yeah take 3 in whatever it's
called in this movie someone Brian Mills
is very close to is killed and he is
then framed for said murder and he's on
the run from the police so he's trying
to figure out who murdered this person
while also proving his innocence and
this is a much better film by the way
taken three was awful I mean it was just
a bad movie and the thing that really
saddens me is that I love Liam Neeson I
mean I loved his pan he's awesome he can
add credibility to anything he can look
at the screen and go I'm a woman and I
believe it but in this movie he is
saddled with not only an idiotic and
dumb script with so many inconsistencies
and so many Hollywood eyes' things that
make you lose all believability that
you're watching something that might
actually happen all those things aside
this movie is directed and edited and
shot to I don't know anything about
Olivia Megaton as a person I'm not
commenting on him as a person for all I
know he's an awesome guy but as a
director of action which he continues to
do transporter 3 Columbiana taken - and
now take three and know I said this in
my review for taken 2 and it seems like
it's true for this movie the action
sequences the median shot length I would
say is less than a second there's a shot
earlier on in the movie where Bryan
Mills hops over a fence this is done in
about 7 different shots that's the kind
of movie you're gonna get with take 3
and I'm going to keep calling it take 3
in because that's the way they marketed
the film and I want to make fun of that
I'm not exaggerating my best way to
describe the way this action affects you
is sometimes when you see a 3d film and
you leave your
sting a little bit because you are
focusing more than usual or because
you're getting assaulted in a lot of
visual ways and your eyes aren't used to
that my eyes stung during the action
sequences in this movie because there
are so many shots that blur by within a
second and they're all shaky and it's
just a barrage of sound effects and
noises to try to subliminally tell you
that there's two people fighting that it
makes your eyes hurt because none of it
looks convincing transporter 3 has Jason
Statham a man who can do action
sequences Columbiana head zoe saldana
juicy Gardens the galaxies she can also
do action sequences this guy who directs
these movies he's taking people who are
fully capable of pulling off awesome
stunt work and he's making it look like
garbage because something in his mind is
telling him that it has to be filmed and
shot this way but it all looks so
horrible
alright so I've talked about the action
it's bad it's terrible it's not a good
action movie it does not look good let's
talk about the plot nothing in this
movie makes sense from scene 1 there are
so many laugh-out-loud moments like Liam
Neeson reading a text that has the word
bagels in it and you actually hear Liam
Neeson go bagels in his head and I
laughed out loud in the theater I'm
sorry no one else laughed aloud it was
hilarious now taken to as a scene that
I've made fun of forever well he
instructs his daughter to throw grenades
off of a rooftop so he can then hear the
sound of the explosions and pinpoint
exactly how far away his daughter is
from him yeah that actually happened
okay so I was waiting for a moment that
dumb in taken three since it's the same
filmmaker I was waiting for a moment
that was that horrific aliy stupid and I
was like wow there actually isn't a
moment that's topping that until the end
of the movie now I'm gonna spoil
something here so if you want to see
taken three warning this isn't really a
huge spoiler but it is kind of a spoiler
but I can't go without talking about
this here we go after stating that his
number one priority is to save his
daughter he then intentionally crashes
the plane that she is in yeah he
intentionally cracked this is a really
dumb stupid movie with terrible action
and an awesome likeable hero
there's some good acting in it from
fomka Jensen and Liam Neeson and Forest
Whitaker is okay although he is playing
the exact same character that he played
in the last stage
and with Arnold Schwarzenegger I'll say
this about this movie it's a watchable
bad movie you can sit there like this
and watch it and you're not going to
want to go like this good thank you can
watch this movie and okay it's on you're
not going to pull a Temple of Doom on
your heart but it's still a awful movie
I'm gonna give take three in a d it's
the exact type of Hollywood crap that
they're trying to make you eat up and
you shouldn't it's not good for you guys
what's your opinion on the taken trilogy
let me know below and as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes